what we're going to do in this video is
practice squaring binomials and this is
something that we've done in the past
but we're going to do it with slightly
more involved expressions but let's just
start with a little bit of review if i
were to ask you what is a plus b squared
what would that be pause the video and
try to figure it out
well some of you might immediately know
what a binomial like this squared is but
i'll work it out so this is the same
thing as a plus b times a plus b and
then we can multiply this a times that a
so that's going to give us a squared and
then i can multiply that a times that b
and that's going to give us a b
then i could multiply
this b times that a i could write that
as b a or a b so i'll just write it as a
b again and then i multiply this b
times that b so plus b squared and what
i really just did is apply the
distributive property twice we go into a
lot of detail in previous videos some
people also like to call it the foil
method either way this should all be a
review if it's not i encourage you to
look at those introductory videos but
this is going to simplify to a squared
plus we have an a b and another a b so
you add those together you get 2 a b
plus b squared
now why did i go through this review
well now we can use this idea that a
plus b squared is equal to a squared
plus two a b plus b squared to tackle
things that at least look a little bit
more involved so if i were to ask you
what is five
x to the sixth plus four
squared pause this video and try to
figure it out and try to keep this and
this in mind
well there's several ways you could
approach this you could just expand this
out the way we just did or you could
recognize this pattern that we just
established that if i have a plus b and
i squared it's going to be this and so
what you might notice is the role of a
is being played by 5x to the sixth right
over there and the role of b is being
played by 4 right over there so we could
say hey this is going to be equal to
a squared we have our a squared there so
what is a squared well 5x to the sixth
squared is going to be 25
x to the 12th power
and then it's going to be
plus 2 times a times b so plus 2 times
5x to the 6th times 4. actually let me
just write it out just so we don't
confuse ourselves 2 times 5 x to the
i'll color code it 2.
2 times
5 x to the 6th
times 4
times 4 plus b squared so plus 4 squared
so that's going to be plus
16. and then we can simplify this
so this is going to be equal to 25 x to
the 12th 2 times 5 times 4 is 40 2 times
5 is 10 times 4 is 40 so plus 40
x to the sixth plus
16.
let's do another example and i'll do
this one even a little bit faster just
because we're getting i think pretty
good at this
so let's say we're trying to determine
what
three t squared minus seven
t to the sixth power squared is pause
the video and try to figure it out
all right we're going to do it together
now so this is our a and our b now we
should view as negative 7 t to the sixth
because this says plus b so you could
view this as plus
negative seven t to the sixth we could
even write that if we want we could
write this plus negative seven t to the
sixth if it helps us recognize this
whole thing is b
so this is going to be equal to a
squared which is nine t to the fourth
plus 2 times this times this 2 times a
times b
so 2 times 3 t squared is going to be 6
t squared
times negative 7 t to the 6th actually
let me write this out this is getting a
little bit complicated so this is going
to be plus 2 times
3 t squared times negative
7 t to the sixth power and then last but
not least we're going to square negative
seven t to the sixth so that's going to
be negative seven squared is positive
49 and t to the sixth squared is t to
the 12th
t to the 12th power and so this is going
to be equal to 9 t to the fourth and
let's see 2 times 3 is 6
times negative 7 is negative 42 and t
squared times t to the sixth we add the
exponents we have the same base so it's
going to be t
to the eighth and then we have plus
49
t
to the 12th power so it looks like we
did something really fancy we have this
higher degree polynomial we were
squaring this binomial that has these
higher degree terms but we're really
just applying the same idea that we
learned many many many videos ago many
many lessons ago in terms of just
squaring binomials